Just to remind you from last time, the structures that we're talking about mostly in this course
are graphs--also sometimes called networks,
which is a discrete structure consisting of a set of nodes--sometimes called vertices--
and edges--sometimes called links.
Interestingly, usually the people who call the nodes "nodes" call the edges "links,"
and the people who call the nodes "vertices" call the edges "edges,"
because these both come from geometry.
But, for whatever reason I mix them together. I apologize.
I tried to change, but it just didn't work.
Here's an example of a graph that has six nodes--the blue circles here--
and one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten edges connecting those nodes together.
In these kinds of graphs, the edges just link up two of the nodes--
not more than two, not fewer than two.
In what we're going to be talking about, the edges don't have any direction to them.
They just link them together.
The particular positioning of them on the page is really irrelevant.
What matters is which nodes are connected to which other nodes.
What we're going to be talking about for the next little while are special networks
that have particular structures and that usually fall into different families.
One particular family of networks is called chain networks.
Chain networks consist of a set of nodes and a sequence of edges between them
that basically connect them into a single chain.
This is an example of a chain network with five nodes--one, two, three, four, five--
and four edges--one, two, three, four--connecting them together.
There's essentially only one such network.
We can imagine flipping it around or relabeling the nodes,
but topologically, there really is only one way of connect five nodes into a chain.
Now, I mentioned that this is part of a family of networks.
Now, you get a different chain network for each different possible number of nodes.
Now, a question I'd like to have you answer is how many edges do you have
in a network that has n nodes if it's a chain network?